un drame évitez de peu à des cartes
dimanche matin l'église
saint-georges-de-la-haye était
heureusement vide qu'on la foudre a
frappé l'édifice provoquant
l'embrasement de la toiture 500 mètres
carrés parti en fumée malgré
l'intervention de 50 sapeurs-pompiers
venus de tout le département et de la
Vienne les fils fragilisés restent sous
surveillance tandis que les œuvres ont
pu être sauvées et que la question de la
reconstruction se pose déjà
les gendarmes devront déterminer les
circonstances exactes du départ de
l'incendie de l'église Saint-Georges de
Descartes mais pour les premiers témoins
cela ne fait aucun doute c'est un
événement naturel qui a causé le
sinistre j'ai entendu un grand coup de
tonnerre effectivement avant qu'il
pleuve et surtout de mon étage j'ai vu
une très très grosse fumée et des
flammes et donc pour situer un peu j'ai
dit oh ça c'est rue des Champs marteau
et puis dès qu'on a entendu les pompiers
avec mon mari on est venu voir
effectivement le clocher était en feu et
puis après toute la toiture vient en
train de brûler une cinquantaine de
sapeurs-pompiers d'Indre-et-Loire et de
la Vienne sont intervenus plus de 500
mètres carrés de toiture sont partis en
fumée les œuvres qui le pouvaient ont
été évacués les autres ont été bâchés à
l'intérieur de l'édifice par les soldats
du feu on doit parfaire l'incendie
puisque il y a encore quelques points
chauds donc c'est pour ça que je
de sécurisation et après comme vous avez
pu voir également sur un autre dame de
paris le feu de référence et ben il y a
des fragilités au niveau de la structure
donc nous prenons l'ensemble des mesures
nécessaires pour que le bâtiment soit
mis en sécurité
s'il est encore trop tôt pour évaluer
précisément l'étendue des dégâts la
question des réparations se pose déjà et
fait écho à la reconstruction de
l'église de Saint-Nicolas-de-Bourgueil
dont la toiture a été emportée il y a un
peu plus de deux ans et dont les travaux
sont espérés pour la fin d'année 2023 il
y aura bien sûr ce que paira l'assurance
mais il y a toujours un reste pour la
commune qui est important et c'est ce
reste à charge pour la commune de
Descartes que avec l'État et d'autres
peut-être la Fondation du Patrimoine on
se penchera pour je dirais parce que
c'est une très grosse dépense la commune
de Descartes on l'aidera fortement
évidemment la messe du dimanche matin 9h
a été annulée c'est l'archevêque de
Tours qui devait la donner en attendant
l'installation du nouveau prêtre le Père
Benoît Laurence qui officier jusqu'ici
dans le bourgueua